it's so funny how
in these in these big you know thousand
page coveted relief bills
they always have these little things
built into them yeah and the last one
trump signed
in uh december 2020 it had in their
they have 180 days for the cia
to release all information on ufos
yeah that was funny so are you guys
what's going on are you guys going to
release that why was that put in there i
think it's already been released
i feel like it's already been released i
think cia already released like two
thousand
two hundred pages of ufo and uh uh
um what was it unidentified aerial
phenomena
but there was nothing really in that
well we don't know first of all
what's really funny is nobody knows
what's really in it because all the
complaints right now from the people who
would be going through it is how
difficult it is
to page through all the documents
because these are like documents from
the 50s and 60s right
paper documents that have been basically
just force-fed through a scanner it's
difficult to sort through all that but
yeah on top of that nothing has been
found
i would say that the reason nothing has
been found is because
cia's authorities cia's
mission is to collect foreign
intelligence
like foreign intelligence that is
foreign nations
that the united states is in some kind
of relationship with
a an unidentified flying object an alien
race
that we are not in any kind of
relationship with would not fall under
your cia's purview right right
most likely it would fall under dod's
per view it might fall under doe's
purview
right it would be totally whack-a-doodle
so it makes sense that cia does have
some documentation on
ufos because as the stuff comes in and
when you look at what has come in from
cia it's like
sightings in foreign countries by
diplomats and whatever else
it makes sense that they would have some
files right but the people who think
that like cia's in charge of area 51 i'm
almost positive area 51 is air force
controlled
right right and then you've got like it
just goes on and on
their authorities have nothing to do
with anything that would ever be
extraterrestrial but that's
that's not what people want to hear
that's not what they believe
that's not what they've been told by tv
shows cia must be in charge of ufos
they've got 2000 pages of documents that
are like 50 years old and they don't
know how to organize
it so i don't think they're in charge
do you think that there's alien beings
flying ships
to the us and we have control of any of
them
i love this question because
when people think ufos when people think
aliens
they're still conditioned from from our
childhood
we're thinking sci-fi right we're
thinking star trek aliens and star wars
aliens we're thinking
humanoid aliens basically right right
what
why aren't we thinking about aliens like
we think about zooplankton in the ocean
like tiny minuscule little living
organisms that you can't even see
why do we think that they're flying in
ships that are visible to us
well because we have reports of them
like like detailed
video reports of them of these things
off the coast like that
the air force pilot the navy pilots the
navy pilots off
in san diego who literally have visuals
of these things
jamming their radars which is an act of
war and going from point a to point b
in less than one second yeah it's an
amazing technology right
but it's it's all something that's
within the realm of what we can imagine
which to me when any whenever you come
across anything that's
that's conventional the most logical
conclusion is that it was made by a
conventional thinker
so it strikes me much more likely that
it's a weapon or some sort of device
that was some sort of technology that
was created by the us or by some other
first world
you know adversary it makes the most
logical sense that somebody else has
created this amazing technology
and and we didn't and we don't know
about it and the first time that we saw
it was here
could it be alien absolutely it could be
alien but
is it like 51 alien 49
it's just developed some other weapon
system in the u.s or some other weapon
system in russia
who knows there's not enough information
to say that is extraterrestrial
technology
there's enough information to say this
looks like
it's something that our radar could even
pick up right it's something that's
flying around in our atmosphere
i think of it like if there is an alien
if there's an alien race out there that
has come to the
has come to the earth and come to the
united states and has observed us
what makes us think that we're even
close enough to their level of
technology
to observe them back even accidentally
what makes us think that's possible
right right i think of it like insects
if you walk over an ant hill right
the ants in the ant hill basically don't
move they don't change anything
because you're so big you're like we as
human beings are so far out of whatever
they deal with day to day
that they don't even see us as a threat
right we're just a thing
so some massive alien technology that
can travel through space at the speed of
light and observe
foreign cultures or observe other
planets they would they would most
likely know how to observe us without us
even knowing that they're observing us
they would be this giant thing that just
flies over and we don't even know it's
there right for whatever reason
they would most likely not be some
little tic tac that we can pick up on
our own radar scanners it's in the
visual
the visual light spectrum what sense
does that make right right because they
would have to know that there's
there's navy ships and navy planes
flying around everywhere especially if
they i mean
i think the uh why would they risk it
when he radioed it in i think they were
like uh
or when he reported it to his to his his
chief or whoever it was
you know above him in the chain of
command he was like right we've been
seeing this
so it's not it wasn't the first time
someone had seen one of those yeah so i
mean it could be anything
it i mean i am not saying it's not alien
what i'm saying is
why why are we pointing to it being
alien so what's the other
what's the other option the other option
is scarier and i think that's why we
point to it being alien
because the other option is that either
american military technology is so
advanced
that we don't even know we can do this
stuff or one of our foreign adversaries
their technology is so advanced that we
didn't even know they were able to do
this stuff
that's the scarier alternate the scarier
ultimate is that that little tic tac
flying around at super speed
is a russian-controlled cruise missile
and they now have that technology and we
don't we
had no idea that it existed that's even
scarier than thinking
that some alien life that is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
is like observing us peacefully like
that's the truth of it
like almost almost all of your major
ufos have always tied back to military
aircraft or military developments of
some sort
right anything that's been exposed
whether it was the sr-71 or the b-2
or even the b-1 right cruise missiles uh
drones
unmanned aerial vehicles all went back
to weaponization
that's they were first seen by some
innocent bystander in the desert nevada
or whatever
and they just proved out to be american
weapon technology
and to weaponize space right yeah well
weaponizing space is a whole different
story like
some people think that we've been doing
it for a long time technically icbms
get shot from space right even what is
an icbm
an inner kind of like an
intercontinental ballistic missile okay
a nuclear missile right
basically goes up into space does a half
of an orbit
and then fires down a warhead like a gun
shoots a warhead down so technically
according to the current
space treaties nothing can be in orbit
around the earth
that is a weapon but things can go into
partial orbit
that are a weapon really yeah yeah
that's the space
i didn't know they went into space like
that yeah yeah and there's i mean that's
why all of our
like the radars the lasers that can that
can
detonate incoming missiles all those
things can be triggered from
you know different parts of the
atmosphere that could be technically
called space
so the weaponization of space is kind of
a funny thing to talk about because
it's kind of happening when china
launched a rocket to blow up a satellite
that then just shattered a satellite and
put you know
tens of thousands of pieces of space
debris that was essentially just a giant
scatter bomb in space so when did they
do that
oh 2010 i think it was when they
they blew up one of their own satellites
with a ground-based missile the hell
would they do that well they claimed
that it was
because the the trajectory of the
satellite was going to bring it into
like some dangerous zone it was going to
land in like a populated city
at the time there was a essential like
spaced gps race with china
so it was largely seen as a show of
force that china was saying
we can shoot your satellites out of
space america if we choose to
and to show you we're going to shoot one
of our own satellites out of space
and then it just created this gigantic
train wreck of flying space debris
that messed everybody up yeah i turned a
bullet into a shotgun exactly
exactly but that's that's the
weaponization of space all within the
confines of the space treaty
that we all said we would never put
orbiting weapons into space
so what wasn't there just like a recent
big show of force
with china what was that in the news i
just i don't know much
i heard i just heard it recently there
was a big show okay they show like their
navy like there's a big naval show of
force
oh that those happen pretty frequently i
mean even amid
even amid coronavirus i'm pretty sure
china did like a military parade
yeah but yeah they've they're very proud
of their navy they're developing their
navy they're developing their
aircraft carrying capabilities their
forward-deployed capabilities from the
sea
like their electoral capabilities are
all on the rise
they invest a ton in terms of a
percentage they
invest a ton of the percentage of their
gdp back into their own military
but i still i'm pretty sure that the
portion even though they invest like
eight percent back into their military
infrastructure
it still pales in comparison to the two
percent that we invest in our own
military capacity
so people get all wound up about china
investing in their future military they
are
but it's it's still they can't compete
you know run men be per dollar against
what we're spending
right and they're you know decades
behind us in terms of
innovation and technology so they're
using old technology
to create new weapons whereas we use new
technology to create new weapons
so it's a it's a completely different
model but one that still makes people
nervous
you